Consider a segment 'AB'.
How would the perpendicular bisector of this segment look?
As the name says, it has to be perpendicular.
And it has to bisect this segment.
Let line 'L' be the perpendicular bisector of this segment
and say it intersects 'AB' at point 'C'.
This will be a right angle.
And length of 'AC' will equal length of 'BC'.
The perpendicular bisector of a segment
divides that segment into two equal parts
and is also perpendicular to it.
Let's erase this and look at perpendicular bisectors in a triangle.
Consider triangle 'PQR'.
If we draw a perpendicular bisector of each side of a triangle,
in all we will have three of them.
The angle bisectors of all the angles of a triangle
always meet at a point.
But do the perpendicular bisectors of the sides of a triangle
also meet at a single point?
Let line 'L' be the perpendicular bisector of segment 'PQ'.
These two sides will be equal and this will be a right angle.
Let line 'M' be the perpendicular bisector of side 'QR'.
That will make these two sides equal
and this angle a right angle.
Now we have to see if the perpendicular bisector of segment 'PR'
passes through this point.
Let line 'N' be the perpendicular bisector of segment 'PR'
and yes, it passes through the same point.
This side will equal this side
and line 'N' will be perpendicular to 'PR'.
So even the perpendicular bisectors of the triangle
meet at point 'C', one single point.
What is this point called?
It's called the circumcenter.
We have seen that the incenter of the triangle
will always lie inside the triangle.
But does the circumcentre always lie inside the triangle?
We see that in the next part of the video.